it is now time you can tell from the
music for The Uplift at eight stories
that will bring you some Joy some new
smile lines to your face some happiness
to your day and Vlad walking streak of
happiness is here to tell us more
because that I could just bounce a ball
and that's the uplift bouncing a ball
coming in at 8 20 7 30
. they love it
I'm glad about the basketball I don't
know you see me turn the channel at
Nate's house I tried to bounce a
basketball he was like come on Vlad it's
a little bit sad you were like I get it
now
uh all right so let me bring you the
story of one child and opening that one
present that you really really wanted to
ever have that feeling when you're a kid
you really really want something so
check out eight-year-old Titan's
reaction when he unwrapped this present
at his birthday party in front of all
his friends
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
at his birthday party in Washington
state his dad told us Titan had been
asking for a phone for a while but he
didn't expect that kind of reaction
you just want the best for your children
and for him to show that emotion I was
not expecting it you know so it just it
did me good I had to hold back a little
tears myself you know
so he said Titan has been loving his new
iPhone and learning new responsibilities
very important that come with owning an
iPhone but I love that all his kids are
like yeah it's okay buddy
but there is a pressure for kids to have
the new technology yes so it runs a
little deeper than just wanting a phone
a sock and sock and robot and a GI Joe
with a constant grip that's all I wanted
times have changed
but it's that age too it's very glad
that was awesome that was an uplift
indeed